[Música]
un pomposo despliegue de Patriotismo
después de que Vladimir Putin declarara
oficialmente la anexión por parte de
Rusia de cuatro regiones ucranianas
un concierto de celebración se llevó a
cabo en la plaza Roja de Moscú para
marcar lo que el presidente ruso llamó
un día especial
nos hemos hecho más fuertes porque
estamos juntos la verdad está de nuestro
lado y el poder reside en la verdad esto
significa la victoria la victoria será
nuestra
unas horas antes Putin firmó unos
documentos junto con los líderes de
Luján Núñez saporiya y gerson designados
por el kremlin al Llamar a Ucrania a la
mesa de negociaciones Putin lanzó una
dura advertencia kiev y occidente
diciendo que Moscú No retrocederá si sus
territorios son desafiados
protegemos nuestro territorio con todas
nuestras fuerzas y medios de los que
disponemos y haremos todo lo posible
para proporcionar una vida segura a
nuestro pueblo Esta es la gran misión de
liberación de nuestro pueblo
los tratados firmados inician el proceso
de absorción de las cuatro zonas
ucranianas que fueron parcialmente
ocupadas por las fuerzas rusas se
produce tras la realización de
referendos organizados apresuradamente
en los que a veces había soldados
armados que iban de puerta a puerta para
recoger votos el proceso ha sido
denunciado por occidente como ilegal e
ilegítimo y un pretexto para una
descarada apropiación de tierras Estados
Unidos y Reino Unido y han anunciado que
van a intensificar las sanciones en
respuesta el kremlin señaló que por
ahora no hay planes para que Putin
visite las regiones anexadas